[Music]  test subject for alpha and for beta  ready to begin hi hi I'm family  yeah okay I'm Marianne guess we're  supposed to get to know each other  do you like dogs or cats better I'm  allergic to both 16 alpha and 16 beta  please really hurt my sciatica  yeah well it's no picnic under here  either man  43 alpha and 43 data that's not on your  neck  Cupid your crystals I'm a Capricorn  personal sachet Aries rising I can also  say meaningless things 56 alpha and 56  feet of have you ever played the cello  no you like to swim no don't you think  some sets are beautiful for my son at  10:30 6:00 a.m. exactly how much cabbage  we had quite a bit  [Music]  how can you say that their  responsibilities primarily to reduce the  chance of electing a mayor ah  and so that was like the third worst  place I ever took a dump  well I guess that settles it Einstein  was right about this one ready to move  on to the next theory yup one output one  beta  [Music]  you  [Music]  Oh